مشاهدينا نستمر بهذه التغطيه للماساه التي
خلفها الزلزال الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
والذي تخطى عدد قتلاه في البلدين حتى الان
20,500 قتيل وقبل قليل وصف الرئيس التركي
كارثه الزلزال بانها الاكبر من نوعها في
تاريخ المنطقه بينما في سوريا اكد وزير
الصحه ان الكارثه كبيره وان تداعياتها
ستكون طويله الامد مناشدا المنظمات
الامميه لتقديم المساعده
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رغم قله الحيله فان الصمود والتشبث بحبل
الامل كاناس سلاح العالقين تحت الانقاض
فمهما طالت الساعات قد تمنحك الحياه فرصه
ثانيه للعيش 72 ساعه مضت على رجلين وهما
ينتظران من ينتشلهما من هذا الركام ساعات
طويله بدات كالدهر
لكن ايادي رجال الانقاذ ابت الا ان تكافئ
انتظارهما بنهايه سعيده اياد قادت جسديهما
المنهكين الى سياره اسعاف تحملهما الى
مكان اكثر امانا
وصل الطلائع الجسر الجوي السعودي الى مطار
اضنه بطائرتين تحملان فريقا مختصا في
الاغاثه والانقاذ الى جانب مستلزمات طبيه
ومساعدات انسانيه وسيستمر الجسر الجوي
خلال الايام القادمه على ان تصل مساعدات
الى المناطق الاكثر تضررا من الزلزال في
تركيا وداخل الاراضي السوريه
عبر هذه الطائره وصل عدد ما يقارب خمسين
من المختصين في طليعه الجسر الجوي السعودي
الذي هي بدا بالذهاب الى تركيا
لاغاثه المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا على حد سواء هؤلاء هم الفريق
السعودي المختص وهم فريق مكون من
من الاطباء والمسعفين والمختصين ايضا
بعمليات الانقاذ الدقيقه وهم سيبداون
اعمالهم مباشره بدءا من الخروج من مطار
اضنه الى الاماكن المتضرره في هذه المدينه
التركيه جراء الزلزال نحن نسعد ان نكون
هنا على الارض قريبين من الحدث وسنكون
الان قريبا خلال الدقائق القليله القادمه
باذن الله عز وجل المتواجدين في اماكن
الاحتياج نوزع هذه المساعدات باذن الله عز
وجل وسننطلق كذلك الى الداخل السوري في
توزيع هذه المساعدات
تركز على هذه المرحله واحتياجاتها وهي
مرحله التدخل الانساني العاجل والطوارئ
هنا من مطار اضنه حيث تتكدس الفرق
التطوعيه وحتى القضيه القادمه من خارج
تركيا لمساعده تركيا على
مساعده متضرري الزلزال هنا فريق سعودي في
الجانب الاخر بينما وصل قبل قليل هنا ايضا
فريق من البرتغال الاغاثي يستعد للخروج من
هذا المطار ويبدو انه مكث طويلا حتى هذه
اللحظه بالاضافه الى الجانب الاخر حيث
يتواجد فريق من التايوان وهي وهو فريق
انقاذي كبير يبدو انه وصل منذ فتره طويله
الا انه حتى الان لم يغادر هذا المطار هذه
هي الحركه في مطار اضنه حيث الكثير من
الفرق التطوعيه في كل في كل زاويه الفرق
الانقاديه من كل دول العالم تاتي الى هذا
المطار
لتبدا على العمليات الانقاديه خارج المطار
في مدينه اضنه او حتى في المناطق المحيطه
المنكوبه في تركيا
مشاهدينا لمزيد من التفاصيل وتحديدا
بسوريا بشمال سوريا من سرمدا ينضم الينا
احمد يازج عضو الدفاع المدني في ادلب
استاذ احمد يعني بالامس كنا نتحدث عن
حاجات كبيره للدفاع المدني لعمليات
الانقاذ عن حاجات المعدات والاليات اليوم
اعلنت عنه الامم المتحده هو يعني معدات
طبيه اغذيه وهي ليست الحاجه الاساسيه
اليوم على الارض ما هي الحاجه الاساسيه
بعمليات الاغاثه
مساء الخير لالكم لجميع المشاهدين لم
يختلف اليوم عن الامس بالنسبه للمساعدات
المساعدات التي دخلت من معبر باب الهوى
اليوم هي عباره عن مساعدات دوريه
من الزلزال فهي عباره عن مساعدات دوريه
تدخل بشكل دوري ولكن انقطع خلال فتره
المساعدات التي تكلمت عنها الامم المتحده
عن دخولها لسوريا
لمساعده
حتى هذه اللحظه اللي نحن حاليا عم نحكي
فيها
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده للمساعدات الموجوده حاليا
هي عباره عن منظمات محليه منظمات مجتمع
مدني
هيئه مدينه
تبرعات عينيه بينما المساعدات الحقيقيه
التي كنا ننتظرها وناسف ان نقول انها سبب
كانت تاخيرها سبب وفاه عدد من المدنيين
اليوم والان كان تحصيل الان
حوالي 1950 فصيل بالاضافه لاكثر من 1950
جريح المعدل الوفيات يزداد اليوم كنت اسال
عنه استاذ احمد يعني اليوم على مئه كم زاد
معدل الوفيات خصوصا ان عمليات الاغاثه
بطيئه لا يوجد امكانات ومعدات وفرق كافيه
وهناك يعني بعض المناطق والابنيه لم يبدا
اصلا العمل بها
جميع فرقنا من توزع لا يوجد للامانه اي
مبنى لا يوجد فيه فريق ولا يتم العمل به
جميع الابنيه المتهدمه طرق الدفاع المدني
متوزعه فيها جميعا ولكن نقول ان تاخر
المساعدات بالنسبه لفرق البحث والانقاذ
المتطوره والتي تساعد جميع الفرق اللي
كانت منتشره
ستساعد كثيرا من
بالامس كانت نسبه الوفيات حوالي كان 1700
شخص اليوم نتحدث عن رقم 1950 فمعدل
الوفيات من 250 شخص هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين
توفوا كان سبب رئيسي تاخر هذه المساعدات
التي نحن بحاجه لها من صعبه
الان فرقنا ما زالت تعمل الى الان هل يوجد
بعض النقاط تم الانتهاء من العمل بها بعض
المباني ولكن يوجد عده نقاط ليتم العمل
بها يوجد عدد غير معلوم عن ضحايا
الموجودين تحت الانقراض
نواصل العمل بالامكانيات المتوفره بين
يدينا الان بعد الانتهاء من عده نقاط يتم
نقل الاليات من نقطه المنتهيه منها من
البحث والانقاذ الى نقطه يتم العمل بها
هكذا كان العمل سابقا يتم البعض المعدات
الى نقاط نتحمل العبث هذا الشيء ولكن هذا
الموجود بين يدي الفرق وبين يدينا كمال
ولكن يعني اليوم كم زادت نسبه الوفيات
بسبب ما تعانون منهم النقص هذا السؤال
الاساسي
خصوصا انك انك اليوم يعني كفرق انقاذ
بحاله سباق مع الوقت كل دقيقه كل ساعه كل
ثانيه تكلف روح اضافيه
عدد الوفيات حوالي
[موسيقى]
عن هذا الاصابه
فكانت هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين توفوا لو ان
سابقنا الزمن وصادقنا الوقت الذي كان
موجود
على قيد الحياه الان ونحن على يقين انهم
سوف يكونون على قيد الحياه لكن
تاخر هذا المساعدات تاخر العمل الظروف
ايضا
الحجم الدمار الكبير التي امتدا على ثمان
سوريا
بالاكمل
بالاضافه للهزات الارتداديه التي ادت الى
سطور كمان عده مباني
بالجراء الهزازات الارتداديه عند هذا
الامر الى تاخير بعض العمل واكبر سبب كان
هو قله امكانيات حلم دمار كبير
اليوم يعني
بموازاه الامكانيات القليله اتحدث عن
المعدات وعن فرق الانقاذ ايضا هناك
احتياجات اخرى للذين يعني يتم تطبيبهم
الذين يحتاجون الى راحه والى نظام غذائي
معين والى اماكن بظل الحاله حاله الطقس
وكل الاوضاع الموجوده هناك على الارض كم
هي صعبه اليوم يعني اذا وصفنا الواقع وما
الذي تحتاجون اليه بهذا الخصوص
بالنسبه للجانب الاراسي والانسان المتعلق
بشق
الخارجين من
المدنيين فكانت جانب كارثه ايضا ما زاد من
معاناه الاشخاص من اهاله الخوف
والهلعاد الضروري والدائم لكي يستمروا على
قيد الحياه
المجال الصحي ان قبل حدوث الزلزال كان
هناك عجز طبي
وقلد نعم دولي بالنسبه للقطاع الصحي مما
ادى الى اغلاق عديد من المشاهده قبل حدود
زلزال وبالاضافه الى
صحفي الدواء عند المدنيه هو الدواء يقومون
بشرائهم
بعد حدوث الزلزال كان هناك معاناه اصلا
زادت هذه المعاناه كانت الفرص عندما يتم
اخر بعض المدنيين الذين بحاجه الى ضباب
وهم على قيد الحياه كانت تذهب الى مشفى
واسلام وثلاثه لكي يتم
استقباله
كامل المشفى الثاني الثالث يوجد كان مسافه
ليست هناك مشاكل ميزانيه
[موسيقى]
ولا حتى كانت سياره الاسعاف المتواجده
لدينا هي عباره عن عياده متنقله كانت تذهب
في المريض وكان هناك عدد طبي
زلزال وايضا كمان المنطقه التي نعمل بها
الان في منطقه سلق سلقين هناك كان انهيار
لسد مائي
الامطار الغزيره التي حصلت منذ يومين
النهار هذا السد المائي مما ادى الى طوفان
في قريه قريه تلال
قريه تلقين مما ادى الى نزوح ايضا جميع
الاهالي من هذه القريه يوجد ايضا فيها
مخيم من اعلى اخراجهم من القريه
وذهابهم ولكن الى اين السؤال الى اين لانه
لا يوجد مراكز ايواء لا توجد قيم الى حد
هذه اللحظه وبالتالي نتحدث عن واقع انساني
صعب ليس فقط عن نقص معدات وغيرها عن نقص
على كافه الصعد شكرا لك استاذ احمد يازجي
عضو الدفاع المدني في ادلب السوري شكرا
على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]
والله
الحمد لله الحمد لله
الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
يلا براءه
عالق تحت الانقاذ ربما لم يصدق ما تراه
عينه هل فعلا كتب له عمر جديد فقد حسب
ربما انه سيموت هنا في هذه الزاويه
المظلمه تحت الركام
تم انقاذ هذا المقيم السوري في تركيا
اطرافه نسيت الحركه حتى تصلبت
جسم مكسر واصوات انين وتاوه كل ذلك قد
يهون الان بعد النجاه
وسط سحابه الحزن العميق التي خيمت على
المكان قد تحمل عمليات انقاذ نبا سارا
عمليه انقاذ قد تضاه عمليه ميلاد جديده
[تصفيق]
لكن هذه المره ميلاد من رحم المعاناه
انقاذ هذا الطفل كان بالنسبه لوالده هديه
من السماء
فرحه النجاه وان كانت كبيره الا انها لم
تمسح دموع الم وصدمات لن تمحيها الايام
معنى مشاهدينا منها تايم العربيه عمار
الهندي عمار يعني مع دخول وحلول الليل
طبعا عمليات الاغاثه تصبح اصعب بسبب
طبعا الطقس البرد وايضا يعني شرح الكهرباء
هناك كيف هي عمليات الاغاثه كيف تسير بهذه
الساعات
وكيف يمكن نقل معاناه رجال الانقاذ من
هناك
اولا عمليات الانقاذ ليال تدخل الان مرحله
حساسه جدا لان اليوم الرابع من هذه
الماساه سينتهي خلال ساعات قليله سنبدا في
اليوم الخامس ونحن لا نزال فعلا من دون
كهرباء في هاتاي مظلمه بالكامل هذا الذي
تشاهدينه من خلف هذا هذه الاضاءه جلبت
للتو يعني عبر سياره فيها مولد
للكهرباء وفيها وتمكنوا من اضاءتها هذا
المبنى هذا الموقع الذي انا فيه
[__] للاسف حتى هذه اللحظه عدد من
العائلات التي لا تزال تحت الانقاض منها
عائلات عائله يمنيه
الام
وابنها وابنتها الشاب للاسف وعمره 16 عاما
فارق الحياه لانه جسده ظاهر يعني جزء من
جسده يعني ظاهر تحت الانقاض ولكن السيده
لا تزال هي وابنتها تحت الانقاض وهنالك
لسوريين ايضا تحت الانقاض عمليات جهود
رجال الانقاذ هم ابطال فعلا ابطال هذه
الماساه لانهم على مدار الساعه يعملون
سواء الاتراك او من تطوع وجاء الى تركيا
هنا ليساعد في هذه العمليات المضنيه
المتعبه جدا جدا ليال ان كنت تشاهدين يعني
تخيلي انت هذا هذا المنظر هذا الركام
الكبير جدا هذا من المفترض ان يزال تماما
حتى يصلوا الى الى الاشخاص سواء ان كانوا
على قيد الحياه او حتى فارقوا الحياه لان
الجميع هنا ينتظر هذه العائلات على يمين
الكاميرا التي ستشاهدينها اشعل النيران
هنا للتدفئه ولن يغادروا هذا المكان حتى
يعثروا على
الذين لا زالوا تحت الانقاض فبالتالي
البرد خالص نعم مع ساعات المساء بدا البرد
فعلا يصبح قار جدا ولذلك هذه العائلات
مستقره طبعا كانت قبل قليل سيده
منهاره جدا وتبكي وتصرخ بان لديها اثنين
من اسرتها تحت الانقاذ وانها تشتكي من قله
وجود كوادر لانقاذ والاليات الثقيله للعمل
ولكن بالفعل الجهود جباره التي تبذل يعني
هنالك من يلوم رجال الانقاذ لانه صاحب
حاجه لانه يريد لاسرائيل لمن لمن يخصه من
تحت الانقاض ان يظهر ويعود الى الحياه ان
كان على قيد الحياه او حتى يعرف مصيره
ولكن في المقابل هذا في الواقع يعني فيه
شيء من التجني لان الجنود كبيره جدا جدا
جدا
ومقارنه وقياسا بالعدد الكبير للمباني
المدمره
هنا في هاتاي المنكوبه من منكوبه تماما
انقطع الاتصال ليان لا اسمعك ولكنني
احتياطا خشيه ان تكوني تتحدثي اليه ساصمت
واترك الكاميرا تلتف وتعطيك صوره عامه عما
يحدث هنا الجهود مستمره لانقاذ
من تبقوا على قيد الحياه مع يعني اقتربنا
من انتهاء اليوم الرابع للاسف والدخول في
اليوم الخامس وهنالك من ينتظر ويريد يعني
من يخصه وان كان قد فارق الحياه
على ما يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال بالزميل
عمار الهندي من منطقه هاتاي
بتركيا وايضا بالصوره نشاهد منطقه غازي
عنتاب ايضا بتركيا يعني هذه المناطق
المنكوبه بعد الزلزال ما زالت اعمال
الاغاثه والبحث عن ناجين ومفقودين مستمره
منذ اربعه ايام وحتى هذه الساعه طبعا مع
ساعات الليل والظلام مع بروده الطقس مع كل
الظروف الصعبه ونقص المعدات ونقص يعني
بالعديد هناك ايضا يعني تصعب المهمه خصوصا
اننا نتحدث اننا دخلنا باليوم الرابع
وبالتالي نحن بدانا ندخل بالمرحله الخطره
والحرجه من ما بعد هذا الزلزال وما بعد
هذه الكارثه عاده بعد على ما يبدو
مشاهدينا هنا فرق الانقاذ تنتشر احد
الضحايا في مدينه
اديمان التركيه اذا ساترك الصوره تتكلم
واعود
[موسيقى]
بالي بالي
على ما يبدو مشاهدينا بهذه الصوره نرى
يعني
[موسيقى]
المصل ما يعرف بالموصل الطبي يتم مده لاحد
الناجين تحت الانقاذ والذي تتم بهذه
الاثناء وبهذه اللحظات عمليه انقاذه من
تحت هذه الانقاذ بعد هذا الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب هذه المنطقه منذ صباح الاثنين
وحتى اليوم طبعا اليوم يعني من صمد تحت
الانقاض بكل هذه الظروف الصعبه اصبح يعتبر
انشاء نحن دخلنا اليوم الرابع
وسندخل يعني غدا اليوم الخامس وهو ما
يعتبر اننا دخلنا بالمرحله الحرجه وكل
ساعه تاخير تعني خساره مزيد من الارواح
وتضاءل الفرص بالعثور على ناجين طبعا
الفرق الطبيه هناك والفرق الانق تقوم
بجهود جباره
لمحاوله انتشال قدر المستطاع ويعني القيام
بما باقصى ما يمكن ان يقام به ولكن طبعا
الكارثه كبيره عدد المباني هائله ونحن
نتحدث عن كارثه غير مسبوقه في التاريخ
التركي ربما في العام 18
بهذا الوقت حصل شيء مشابه ولكن اليوم
نتحدث عن اضرار كبيره عن خسائر بشريه
وايضا خسائر
يعني
بالمباني وبالطرقات وهو ما يصعب عمليه
الوصول الى بعض المناطق وعمليه الانقاص
طبعا وعلاوه على كل ذلك ايضا الظروف
المناخيه والظروف الطبيعيه لهذه المناطق
على ما يبدو
تم يعني تم انتشال شخص من تحت الانقاض وتم
انقاذ احد
المواطنين الاتراك من تحت الانقاذ ويتم
عمليه تتم عمليه اغاثه بهذه الاسنان وطبعا
اعطاءه الاسعافات الاوليه القيام
بالاسعافات الاوليه المطلوبه لنقل طبعا
الى المستشفى او اي المراكز الطبيه
الميدانيه التي اقيمت هناك بظل اقتضاض
المشافي وطبعا المراكز الميدانيه على امل
ان يكون بصحه جيده وان يعني تزداد الحالات
المشابهه التي يمكن القول بانهم ناجين
طيله هذا المساء وطيله عمليه البحث
والانقاذ حتى لا نخسر ارواح اكثر بهذا
الزلزال المدمر
عاد الزميل عمار الهندي منها طايا عمار هل
تسمعني
نعم نعم عمار كنا نتابع عمليه انقاذ احد
المفقودين من تحت الركام هل صحته جيده هو
طفل هو مسن يعني
ما الوضع من هناك لو سمحت
عمار طبعا حالات عديده
نعم هنالك حالات عديده اليوم يعني انا انا
كنت موجود في مقربه من بنايه تم استخراج
شخص كان على قيد الحياه منها
وهنالك ايضا بنايه ثانيه تجري فيها عمليه
حساسه جدا دقيقه لاخراج ثلاث شبان محاصرين
احدهم احدهم اجاب على اتصال هاتفي من
اقربائه وابلغهم بانه على قيد الحياه
وكانت هنالك اجهزه للفحص ولكن المشكله
الحقيقيه في تلك الحاله بان بان هؤلاء
الشبان محاصرون في تسويه لمبنى لم ينهار
بعد وبالتالي فرق الانقاذ اخلت المنطقه
بشكل كامل لانهم توقعوا في اي لحظه ان
ينهار هذا المبنى في حاله حدث اي خلل في
خلال الحفر في التسويه وهنا هذا ما يجيب
على تساؤل عن اهميه وجهود رجال الانقاذ
انا متاكد بانهم يعني متاكد انهم يجازفون
في حياتهم في لحظات كثيره يعني في هذه
اللحظه اللي كنا ننظر اليها في تلك
البنايه هم يعني لديهم شعور وكبير جدا
بانه هذه البنايه يمكن ان تسقط في حال
استمروا في عملهم لانقاذ اشخاص يعتقدون
انهم على قيد الحلاوه على قيد الحياه ورغم
ذلك يستمرون في العمل جهود جباره هنا الان
وانا يعني معك على الهواء جاءت اعداد
كبيره من رجال الانقاذ والمتطوعين
تشاهدينهم في الشاشه الى هذا الموقع لانه
هذا الموقع من المواقع الكبيره جدا هي
بنايتين وفيها عشرات العائلات لا تزال تحت
الانقاض وبالتالي جاءت هذه التعزيزات انا
متاكد ايضا العيال بان بعض رجال انقاذ لم
يناموا ربما من ليالي متعدده يعني
لانهم يواصلون الليل وبالن الليله بالنهار
وهنالك يعني مطالب كبيره جدا من الاسر ومن
اسر المفقودين تحديدا لاستمرار العمل ولا
وكنت اتحدث بانه من لديه مفقود تحت
الانقاذ لا اي شيء يهمه فقط ان يعثر على
هذا الشخص المفقود ويتوصل اليه ويعرف
مصيره وبالتالي هنا يقع ربما احيانا الظلم
على رجال الانقاذ وجهودهم وما يقومون به
من اعمال فعلا بطوليه لانه مهما وصفت لك
لا استطيع فعلا ان اوفيهما الجهود التي
يبذلونها وهذا طبعا ليس فقط هنالك متطوعين
كثر يعني هنالك وفود جاءت من من عديد
الدول تساعد في هذه العمليات التي تستمر
لليوم الرابع الذي هو على وشك ان ينتهي
وندخل في اليوم الخامس وهذا كله في سباق
مع الزمن اكثر شخص يستطيع ان يشعر في هذا
السباق مع الزمن للوصول الى المفقودين هو
رجل انقاذ نفسه
وطبعا يعني
الناس واهالي وذوي الضحايا او المفقودين
الذين ينتظرون لمعرفه اي خبر عن اقربائهم
عنهم عن جيرانهم ربما هي طبعا لحظات انت
صعبه جدا وماساويه كما نشاهد بالصوره عمار
يعني كيف يفترشون الارض كيف
يجلسون بجانب المباني المدمره
لعل يعني يتم انقاذ ذويهم تحت هذه المباني
وتحت هذا الركام عمار يعني طبعا هناك جهود
جباره لرجال الانقاذ هناك كي اليه العمل
وكيفيه العمل طيله هذا النهار هل هناك
تناوب بينهم وكم بلغ يعني معدل الضحايا
مقارنه بالامس
لا يمكن ان اعتقد لا يمكن ان يعني ان
يغادر اي رجل انقاذ مكانه لانه هنالك نقص
كبير جدا ليال بمعنى يعني هم ربما يستريح
قليلا ولكنه يواصل العمل ربما انا رايت
بعضهم ينام في الموقع نفسه يعني لديهم
خيام ينصبونها في الموقع نفسه ينام ربما
ساعتين ومن ثم يواصل العمل عوضا عن زميله
لانهم كما قلت لك يعني يسابقون الزمن ما
في ما في اي اي شيء يعني يغني الانسان ان
يصل الى شخص على قيد الحياه بعد ان حاصره
هذا الزلزال وهذه الانقاض بالتالي انا
اعتقد انه طبعا كنت سالتيني عفوا عن اليه
العمل اليه العمل التي تجري هي اذا سمعوا
اذا شعروا بان هنالك شخص على قيد الحياه
او صدرت ايه اشارات منه صوت او رده فعل
عند عند السؤال ما اذا كان هنالك احد تحت
الانقاض تتغير اليه العمل تتوقف الاليات
الثقيله ليال عن العمل وتبدا ويبدا عمليات
البحث بادوات بسيطه خشيه تعريض حيات هؤلاء
الناجين تحت الانقاض للخطر وبالتالي هنا
يعني هذا التكنيك الذي يحدث طبعا بحد ذاته
مرهق
يتغير
يعني السؤال الذي نساله كل يوم وطبعا لم
يكن هناك اجابه عليه لا ادري اذا ما كان
هناك اي اجابات توضحت بخصوص هذا الشان هل
صدرت اي ارقام تقديريه عن اعداد المفقودين
تحت الانقاض لمعرفه يعني كم ستستغرق بعض
هذه العمليات
ليال انا اعتقد انه من المستحيل الاجابه
على هذا السؤال انا اؤكد لك انني بالامس
واليوم ذهبت الى احياء مدمره بالكامل في
داخل هذه المدينه في عمقها احياء سكنيه
مدمره بالكامل لم تصل حتى اللحظه لم تبدا
فيها حتى اللحظه عمليات الانقاذ انا لا
اعتقد هذا الموضوع كارثه نقودين نتحدث عن
مناطق باكملها لن تبدا فيها عمليات
الانقاذ
صحيح واليوم انا اليوم وثقنا على الهواء
بنايات هنا في المنطقه لم تبدا فيها
عمليات الانقاذ لانه هنا السؤال ياتي عن
الاولويه لمن الاولويه الاولويه للبنايه
التي التي يصدر منها صوت ويعتقد ان فيها
اشخاص على قيد الحياه ولكن هل سؤال مهم هل
جميع البنايات قام احد باستكشاف ما اذا
كان سيصدر منها صوت الاجابه حتما له
وبالتالي كما قلت لك الامور ربما تسير
باليه صعبه ومعقده جدا لان الكارثه كبيره
يعني انا لا اوجد مبرر لذلك ولكن الكارثه
كبيره كبيره جدا وفي نفس الوقت الاعداد
التي تشارك في هذه العمليات لا تغطي حجم
الكارثه نعم هنالك ونحن نتحدث عمار عن فرق
اغاثيه ومعدات وصلت تقريبا من كل دول
العالم والصوره هي على ما هي عليه يعني
صوره كارثيه بهذا صحيح صحيح صحيح طائرات
عسكريه تنقل في هاتاي انا اراها لانه مطار
هاتاي هو المطار الوحيد الذي لا يزال مغلق
لانه تعرض لتشققات التصدعات في في مبانيه
وبالتالي لا يعمل المروحيات العسكريه
وطائرات عسكريه تنقل معدات وتنقل فرق
انقاذ الى هاتاي على مدار الساعه كل هذا
كل هذا ليال نعم الاجابه انه نعم هنالك
احياء وبنايات كبيره وكثيره لم تبدا فيها
عمليات الانقاذ بعد وانا اتوقع اننا نحتاج
ربما الى اسبوع اخر حتى تبدا هذه العمليات
لانه الدمار ورقعه الدمار كبيره وهذه
الفرق واعدادها لا تستطيع ان تتجاوب مع كل
هذا الكم الهائل من الدمار وهذا
ما نتحدث وشهاداتي السبب عندما نتحدث عن
اسبوع اضافي يعني نحن نتحدث عن يومين او
ثلاثه ايام التي فيها امل وجود احياء
ويعني
يكون حالات استثنائيه اتحدث عن القاعده
العامه هي اربعه ايام الى سبعه ايام
للاسف نعم نعم لانه هنالك انا وانا اتحدث
الى الناس صراحه يعني حتى اشخاص لديهم
يعني اقارب تحت الانقاذ يعني مع مساء هذا
اليوم بداوا يفقدوا الامل بداوا يفقدوا
الامل بان هنالك يعني امكانيه ان ينجو احد
تحت الالقاب انا بصراحه دائما الامل موجود
والدليل انه اليوم تم اخراج اشخاص من تحت
الانقاض لا يمكن الجزم ولكن كما تحدثتي
القاعده الاشمل لهذا الامر انه يعني
من الصعب ان يعني ان يمكث الانسان اكثر من
اربع ايام دونما دون طعام تحت الانقاض
وربما التنفس يكون فيه صعوبه وربما تكون
انهيارات الى انه هذه المباني في داخلها
يعني تحدث انهيارات طبعا
لانه عمار عمليه يعني عمليه سقوط هذه
الابنيه كانت سريعه نتحدث عن زلزال قوي
جدا وبالتالي يعني هي متراكمه بطريقه
ومتراصه بطريقه صعبه جدا
بعمليات
وايضا يعني الانهيارات التي تحصل بالداخل
تصعب هذه العمليه وتصعب يعني اذا ما كان
هناك ناجين فعلا تحت هذه الاوقات كيفيه
تتعامل الفرق الانقاذيه مع هذا الموضوع
يعني انا هذا موضوع مهم للغايه فعلا انه
هنالك طبعا بنايات اولا هنالك بنايات
تعرضت للزلزال انهار اجزاء منها مالت بشكل
كبير
وتنهار تدريجيا يعني تقع منها اجزاء تمام
هنالك بنيات انهارت وفي داخلها انهيارات
اصلا يعني تحدث في داخلها انهيارات اعمال
الحفر وهنا السؤال الاجابه اعمال الحفر
بالاليات الثقيله
خطيره جدا لانه اذا ما كان اذا ما اذا لم
يسمع بالاحرى اذا لم يسمع صوت لناجين داخل
هذا الركام او هذه البنايات يتم استخدام
الاليات الثقيله كما تشاهدي هنا في الصوره
الان مثلا العمليات تجري باستخدام الاليه
الثقيله لذلك اليوم احدى زميلات سالتني هل
استخدام الاليات الثقيله في الحفر
مؤشر الى عدم وجود ناجين تحت هذه الانقاض
وكانت الاجابه بصراحه صعبه علي يعني لا
استطيع ان اقول نعم ولكن ما يحدث هنا انه
اذا تدخلت الاليات الثقيله في مبنى ما او
فيما نقطه ما فهذه اشاره لانه ليس هنالك
اي احد ناجي اعمار هل هذا الحفر باستخدام
المرحله هل يتم استخدام الاليات التي ترصد
النبض تحت تحت الركام باختصار لو سمحت ما
علمته انها استخدمت اليوم ما علمته ان هذه
الاجهزه المتطوره استخدمت اليوم مره واحده
وبشهاده شخص من قريب للشبان السوريين اكد
لي بانه فريق انقاذ اردني جاء ليساعد هنا
في هاتاي يمتلك هذه الاجهزه وهو الذي قام
بفحص التسويه على عمق سته امتار وهو الذي
الفريق الذي اكد انه باستخدام هذه الاجهزه
هنالك نبض وهنالك حياه لاشخاص تحت المبلغ
ولذلك جاءت فرق الانقاذ واعتمدت على هذه
الصور واعتمدت على هذا العمل وبدات نعم
بالبحث عنهم نعم خصوصا ان
متوفره بكثره شكرا لك
عمار الهندي موفد العربيه منها طاي
مشاهدينا منها طايسه انتقل الى اضنه ومفرد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن
يعني مع بدء ووصول الجسر الجوي الاغاثي
السعودي الذي يعني بدا بايصال المساعدات
الى هناك كيف هي الصوره كيف تتم عمليه
توزيع هذه المساعدات الانسانيه التي يعني
بدا بها مركز الملك سلمان للمساعدات
الانسانيه
نعم ليالي بالفعل منذ صباح هذا اليوم وصل
هذا الجسر الجوي وطلعت هذا الجسر الجوي
عبر طائرتين الى اضنه هنا حيث المنطقه
التي يتواجد بها المطار الذي يستطيع ان
يستوعب كل هذه الطائرات وهذا النوع من
المساعدات نظرا لان كل المطارات الاخرى في
الجنوب التركي اما تعرضت لضرر جزئي او
ليست قادره على استقبال هذا النوع من
الطائرات فبالتالي طائره شحن اليوم
السعوديه هبطت
بجعبتها ما يقارب 90 طن من المساعدات
الاغاثيه والايوائيه والطبيه وكذلك
الغذائيه على كل المستويات التي تم
التنسيق مع الجانب التركي حيالها بخصوص
الاحتياجات بشكل مباشر بالاضافه الى ان
جزء من هذه المساعدات بدات فعليا
بالذهاب عبر الشاحنات الى الحدود السوريه
تحديدا حدود التركيه السوريه عبر اما
انطاكيا او غازي في تلك المعابر التي
سيدخل فيها في هذا المعبرين تحديا هذين
الذي سيدخل من خلال اعاده تدخل هذه
المساعدات من خلالها الى الداخل السوري
وتحديدا شمال غربي سوريا نظرا للحاجه
الكبيره جدا للمساعدات في تلك المنطقه
بالاضافه الى استمرار عمليه المساعدات في
المناطق التركيه المختلفه في الحقيقه وصل
ايضا عدد كبير من
الفرق الطبيه والاسعافيه وحتى فرق الانقاذ
السعوديه صباح هذا اليوم وبدات فعليا
بالعمل والتنسيق مع الاجانب التركي تحديدا
اليوم كان هنالك اجتماعات مع
ايفاد وهي الجهه المسؤوله عن تنظيم وعمل
الجهات الاغاثيه في تركيا تحديدا في هذه
الكارثه فبالتالي
النقاش معاهم والتباحث حول الاليات العمل
وكذلك المناطق الاشد حاجه والاكثر ضررا
والتي يحتاج وتحتاجها المساعدات بشكل
مباشر وتحتاج للمساعدات بشكل مباشر وتحتاج
التدخل السعودي بشكل مباشر او فريق
السعودي يوم غد ايضا العيال عند الصباح
مباشره
سيصل فريق من الدفاع المدني مكون من اكثر
من 50 شخص الدفاع المدني السعودي مختصين
بعمليات الانقاذ وعمليات التي تتم في
عمليات البحث عن ناجين في مناطق مختلفه في
تركيا وايضا المساعده على مساعده الفرق
التركيه وكافه الفرق الاغاثيه الدوليه
العامله في هذه
المساعدات بشكل مباشر في الحقيقه الامطار
كلها بدات تتجه على المساعدات نظرا لانه
يتواجد ما يقارب خمسه عشر الى عشرين مليون
شخص يحتاج الى المساعده ليس فقط من هم تحت
الركام ويحتاجون الى الاخراج ولكن حتى
المتواجدين في المخيمات المتواجدين في
الشوارع وفي العراء لا يجدون منازل يبيتون
بها في ظل هذا البرد القارس فبالتالي
العمليات اليوم ايضا شاهدت في مطار اضنه
عدد كبير جدا من الفرق الدوليه التي
تواجدت للفرق الاغاثيه الدوليه التي
تواجدت بجانب مركز الملك سلمان
بعمليات
المساعده والاغاثه بشكل مباشر فرق من
اوروبا فرق من شرق اسيا بالاضافه الى مركز
الملك سلمان يعملون سويا في الحقيقه
فرق ايقافيه دوليه من كافه القارات اليوم
شاهدتها بالاضافه الى تواجد يعني مناظر من
خلال هذه المدينه وهذه المنطقه في اضنه
التي لم تتاثر كثيرا بالزلزال ولكن هي
متاثره بشكل غير مباشر وهنا وهنا اتحدث عن
النازحين الذين سقطت منازلهم حيث شاهدت في
مختلف الشوارع هنا بعض الخيام المتواجده
على اطراف الشوارع
لاشخاص اما سقط منازلهم او اصبحت خطرت جدا
لا يستطيعون الدخول اليها فبالتالي
يتواجدون هم في العراء وفي مخيمات
المنظمات الدوليه نتابع معك اليات وعمليات
وصول المساعدات الاغاثيه التي سيارتها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عبر الجسر الجوي
السعودي شكرا لك عبد المحسن الحربي بمفرد
العربيه من اضنه
منام اللي صار فينا منام
يا ولدي يا ولدي
وصلت على الدرجه تحت قلبت فينا البنايه
انا من هون من تحت السقف تحتي ضليت كم
ساعه عيط عيط عيط بعدين سكتت اشهدت اخر
نفس واحد لحتى سمعني بس انا شايفه جوزي
تحت السقف وفي اولاد جسس فوقي
وفي شو اسمه
في اولاد كتير فوقي كانوا
بعدين شو اسمه
جابولي ابني قالوا لي عايش تروح انت ضل لي
واحد تروح
صلاه
شو بده يصير اكثر من هيك يا عمي شو بده
يصير
مدري في حلب ينضم الينا على الصحافه احمد
ابو لؤي استاذ احمد يعني امام هول هذه
الكارثه طبعا هناك امكانات عديده مفقوده
بالشمال السوري يعني بتركيا مع كل
الامكانات مع كل فرق الانقاذ التي وصلت
الى هناك ومازلنا نتحدث عن مناطق باكمله
لم تصلها عمليات وفراق الاغاثه كيف هي
الصوره من حلب
نعم فعلا كما
يعني
اوضاعيه
لو سمحت ممكن ان تغير وضعيه الجلوس ربما
الارسال ضعيف
سنحاول العوده اليك استاذ احمد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
فرق الانقاذ في سوريا تواجه نقصا حادا في
المعدات اللازمه لانتشال ضحايا الزلزال من
تحت الانقاد ما يعرقل طبعا عمليات الاغاثه
هذه العباره تستخدم الان في لحظات سعاده
بانقاذ احد ناجين من تحت الانقاض او خيبه
امل باستخراج جثه هامده كلا الجسدين
يلتفان بالبطانيات فرق الانقاذ في سوريا
تعمل بكافه طاقتها الاستيعابيه لانقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه ازاله الانقاض وتوثيق الضحايا
الا ان نقص المعدات الاكثر اساسيه يجعل
العمليات بدائيه لتكون البطانيات هي
النقالات الوحيده الموجوده في الميدان
وتكون بقايا الملابس الممزقه ضمادات لجراح
بعض الناجين
وضع يتفاقم ويتازم بمرور الوقت فالكارثه
لم تتوقف بتوقف الزلزال بل كل تاخير في
وصول المساعدات من المعدات الاساسيه
والطبيه يزيد عدد الضحايا لتكون مقابل كل
ساعه تاخير 50 حاله وفاه تقول تقديرات فرق
الانقاذ الاليات المتوفره بين يدي فريق
الدفاع المدني المؤديات هي صراحه غير
كافيه لحتى حتى ينجز العمل بشكل سريع وحتى
نسحب العالقين من تحت الانقاب بشكل سريع
الكارثه الطبيعيه التي حلت بالشمال السوري
زادت موتا على الموت الذي يواجهه سكان
المنطقه كل يوم من اوضاع انسانيه صعبه
ثلاث سنين الحرب السوريه الطويله ونزوح
وفقر وحصار وحاجه ملحه مستمره للمساعدات
تضاعفت في ظل زلزال القرن
[موسيقى]
ولم تكن مناطق سيطره النظام في سوريا افضل
حالا ليعترف الاخير ويقر بان البلاد ليست
مهيئه لتبعات هذا النوع من الكوارث وتعاني
نقصا حاديا في المعدات اللازمه لرفع
الانقاض والمعدات الطبيه ايضا عمر العربيه
الساعه 4:12
[موسيقى]
اعود مجددا مشاهدينا الى ريف حلب والصحافه
احمد ابو لؤي استاذ احمد يعني هل ممكن ان
تسمعنا بشكل واضح
كنا نتحدث عن الوضع الماساوي هناك كيف هي
الصوره من هناك مع كل النقص الذي تعانيها
منطقه ريف حلب نتحدث عن نقص هائل بالمعدات
وبالعديد يعني ليس هناك فرق انقاذ كافيه
للقيام باعمال الانقاذ ونحن دخلنا اليوم
الرابع بعد هذه الكارثه كيف هي الصوره من
هناك
كارثه تتفاق
الغربي سواء في شمال حلب
طبعا
في منطقه جنبيه
ما زال هناك صعوبه بسماع يعني الصوت متقطع
بطريقه كبيره يعني هناك استحاله ان نفهم
الكلمات
شكرا لك استاذ احمد ابو لؤي على امل يعني
ان نكون معك مجددا فور جهوز الاتصال
بطريقه مختلفه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انقاذ قد تبدو غير منصفه احيانا فهم اكثر
من رجال يقومون بمهامهم بل هم في اعين
منكوبين نافذه هروب من الموت المحتوم
رؤيتهم في حد ذاتها قد تعيد الروح
لاصحابها كما هو حال هذه الطفله
تقابله تطمينات لينتهي السجال بانقاذ هذه
الطفله الصغيره التي قاومت انقادا جثمت
على جسدها الصغير طويلا
[موسيقى]
سلامتك يا روحي انت
يلا هلا بتنامي ان شاء الله هلا بتنامي يا
عمري
[موسيقى]
ارفع الباب
مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره لهذه
الكارثه التي حلت بكل من تركيا وسوريا بعد
زلزال المدمر وطبعا مواكبه عمليات اغاثه
الناجين والمفقودين من تحت الانقاد والان
الى نبيل